spider-man far from home is almost just
a week away and right now it's really
all anybody can talk about how's it
going everyone it's Warren and today we
have a full plot leak for spider-man far
from home so it's a great day if you are
into leaks and spider-man and if you are
not I must issue an official spoiler
alert because there are some major
spoilers in this plot leaked but of
course with all plot leaks take it with
a grain of salt there is obviously a
chance that it may not be true we've
gotten a lot of plot leaks in the past
including the full plot leaks and for
post-credit scenes however a lot of the
leaks that we got in the past were
before spider-man far from home was
actually screened now it has officially
been pre-screened so there are people
that have seen it and know exactly what
happened so this leak could very much be
100% real also don't forget to subscribe
to my channel so you can enter my Marvel
legend item giveaway I'll be picking
three new winners at four hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers okay one last
fuller warning because we're jumping
right into it the beginning starts with
a montage of the Dead heroes from the
events of endgame this is a video that
was put together by Peter himself
Mysterio tries to become Peters new
mentor Mysterio manipulates Peter uses
Tony Stark and Iron Man visions against
him Aunt May sneaks in Peter's blue /
red suit in his luggage Mysterio is from
the regular MCU world he was lying about
coming from another world
Becky used to work for Stark stole some
tech and tried to become the new hero in
lieu of Iron Man we find out that a
small handful of peter's classmates and
teachers were snapped while the others
have aged up five years peter is
introduced to new high tech that
belonged to iron man with the help from
happy and fury there is no Tony Stark AI
and Peter suit or in this high tech lab
this is where Peter makes the new black
and red suit the stealth suit was
provided by fury until but Peter thinks
it's too clunky Mysterio makes
projections drone equipment and other
things to make Moulton man Hydra man and
the others and spider-man far from home
MJ and Peter will be officially dating
Ned and MJ destroy some of the drones
this is where the Funko pop of MJ with a
mace comes into play if you've been with
me this far I just got to issue one more
spoiler alert because we're going to get
into some major spoilers right now with
the ending of the film and the
post-credits scenes and the final battle
Mysterio dies and
the post-credits scene he somehow
releases in edited video showing that
Peter Parker is spider-man and was
responsible for the attacks J jonah
Jameson is back and played yet again by
JK Simmons which is a video that I did a
couple of days ago and the other post
credit scene
Talos and another scroll were asked to
take fury in his place on earth while
the real ones are on holiday this is why
fury gets mad at Peter earlier in the
film for mentioning Captain Marvel it's
actually a scroll we don't see any
aftermath of Peters identity getting
revealed as it cuts out just like how
Mays reaction in the first spider-man
homecoming post-credit scene cut out
there is no chameleon there is no Osborn
there is no Pepper Potts there is no
barf there is no Morgan Stark there is
no vulture no scorpion or hints at any
other of Spidey's rogue Gallery so this
plot leaked really does make a lot of
sense and really does go hand-in-hand
with everything that we've seen so far
one thing that makes a lot of sense is
Mysterio working for Stark Industries
it's a little bit of a story change from
the comics but if you have read those
comics or if you have been following my
channel you know that Mysterio
desperately wants to be a hero and if he
worked for Stark Industries he has to be
pretty smart and in the comics he was
pretty smart as well but he was really
good at special effects but now it seems
like they're making him some sort of an
engineer that works for Stark Industries
which makes a lot of sense because a lot
of people were wondering about his suit
initially some people thought that his
suit could be made of Chitauri tech
especially since in spider-man
homecoming many people were trying to
collect re tech because in some of the
scenes that we've seen for spider-man
far from home Mysterio is able to fly
pretty seamlessly but now it makes
perfect sense knowing that it is stark
tech now according to this leak they
obviously kept the part about Mysterio
being somewhat of an illusionist in this
film the leak says that Mysterio uses
projections drone equipment and other
things to make the elementals and this
is something that people thought for a
very long time now that the elementals
aren't actually real they're not from
another dimension but they're simply
made by Mysterio now that Tony Stark is
gone Mysterio wants to be the hero and
how
you become a hero well you have to
defeat some villains and the easiest way
to defeat a villain is to make your own
but then of course everybody is looking
at Peter Parker slash spider-man to be
the new Iron Man so now he has to take
out spider-man and evidently when he
does that he dies in the final battle
however it does say that in one of the
post-credits scenes even though Mysterio
has died he somehow manages to leak a
video that makes it look like spider-man
is in fact the bad guy and of course
this is the post-credits scene that I
mentioned a couple of days ago in the
video i did where j jonah Jameson is
back and played by the original actor JK
Simmons of course
good old JJJ is known for making
spider-man out to be a villain which is
very ironic and will be very interesting
to see in the post-credits scene and in
the next spider-man film because in
spider-man far from home everybody is
looking at spider-man to be a hero to be
the next Iron Man and now JJ Jay is
going to peg him out to be a villain so
I'm wondering how the world will react
to that and wondering if it's going to
play a pretty big part in the next
spider-man film but then we have the
other post-credit scene with the scroll
this is not the first time that I heard
this was one of the post-credits scenes
for spider-man far from home
Talos and another scroll taken the place
of fury and he'll while they're on
vacation makes perfect sense to me
we know that Talos and fury worked
together and got very close and Captain
Marvel now at the end of Captain Marvel
Talos seemingly left the solar system
with Captain Marvel but we do know that
Nick Fury has a way to contact them with
his cosmic pager and after everything
that fury and he'll have gone through
over the last 10 years and getting
snapped it would make sense that they
would want to break but them being who
they are they can't just leave so they
would need somebody to take their spots
who would look exactly like them so the
scroll are the perfect choice and this
also clarifies something that I think a
lot of people have been very suspicious
about and that is Nick Fury trusting
Mysterio Nick Fury is the master spy we
know he doesn't really trust anybody but
we also know that he picks up on
everything so a lot of people were
worried that he would trust Mysterio
when we all know that he's really the
villain but if it wasn't him if it was
in fact Talos this would make perfect
and this does in fact explain the one TV
spot that we have where Peter mentions
Captain Marvel and fury says don't
invoke that name that scene kind of
confused people when they saw it but now
it makes sense considering the fact that
it's Talos and then evidently there's
going to be a lot of characters that we
thought were going to be in the movie
and thought we've actually seen in the
movie that are not going to be in the
movie but again take this leak with a
grain of salt yes the movie has been
pre-screened yes people have seen it and
it does sound like for the most part
that it could be legitimate but you
never know however be sure to comment
with your thoughts on this do you like
how this plays out for spider-man far
from home or would you like to see
something else comment with your
thoughts and favorite superhero or
villain also like the video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to spider-man far
from home and Marvel as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof